C a dit cette samba
perdu, où va-t-il
On dit qu'il est allé de l'avant sans
consulter le
personne pour comprendre la samba, pas toi
tu dois partir là où est la samba
la samba est dans le sang de ceux qui sa
samba, la samba est là, la samba est là
alors la samba est dans le sang de qui sait
samba
C'est aussi sous l'aisselle de Cacique de R
C'est au pied de l'église de Penha dans le train
le centre se trouve sur la Praça Mauá, dans la rue
les domaines reci nos sont également entrés dans l'histoire en
Bahia on dit même que la samba y est née
ici le
la samba est dans ce sang
cette samba est là, la samba est là, la samba
Il y a du sang
de ce B
samba quand il descendait du moua
est descendu dans le bon sens, a exprimé son émotion
la samba a voyagé en avion, la samba a voyagé en avion
Canoa, samba a peint le décor de Dame Valete
tu sais à quoi ressemble la samba, c'est dans ta tête
paume de la main et sur la plante du pied, la samba est
Alors la samba est dans le sang des queç sa
Samba la samba est là la samba est là la
la samba est dans le sang de ce sa
samba, je vais demander à São Jorge ce que c'est
ça me fait mal de me bénir
le sang de celui-là sort samba je vais
samba la nuit et le jour, je le savais
Avant
se marier est dans le sang de cette personne, tu sais
se marier
merci